foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined this hour by Dr John
deloney that's right he is a doctor
ladies and gentlemen two phds
best-selling author host of the Dr John
deloney show what do you mean not really
John they weren't honorary I can't heal
anybody I went to a lot of grad school
classes the marathon I get to put the
sticker on my car that says 26 Point
whatever like I walk I finished I didn't
win the marathon that's a good point but
there is a it's funny that people go
well you're not a real doctor but you
can have a doctorate and be a doctor and
not be a medical doctor correct correct
people need to understand that but
there's also people who have like
doctorates in totally unrelated things
that like anyway I tend to ask you about
my health symptoms though frequently
you answer with confidence I shouldn't
be doing that I love it well uh John I
thought it would be fun while we wait on
the phones to start ringing triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call by the way that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we want to talk about your
money your mental health your
relationships boundaries whatever goals
you have whatever Crossroads you're
facing we want to step in and help you
take the right Next Step so triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call and we'll get you on the
phones here
so I want to start John with our
question of the day which comes from
Fernando in Arizona what does Fernando
have to say all right Fernando asks what
I should do to get out of my dad's house
and out of debt while looking to get
married
Fernando you got a lot going on man I'm
a manager for a financial institution
call center making 68 000 before taxes
and have 9 000 bucks in my 401. I still
live at my dad's house and I pay the
utility bills I'm looking to move out of
my dad's house but Arizona home prices
are still high I have over twenty
thousand dollars in debt spread between
credit cards past due taxes set up on a
payment plan and 401K loans
I believe my dad would hey taking up
401K loans I believe my dad may be able
to lend me money to knock out some
credit card debt that would help a lot
since I'm paying over 25
APR rate however I've never asked him
for anything since I was 14 years old I
guess except for a place to live and
rent
I'm not sure if I should ask my dad for
money or how to ask him if I do
oh Fernando Fernando oh Fernando we have
no clue how old Fernando is I don't
think he mentioned that he could be 50
he could be 20. that's right no clue
we're gonna guess he's closer to 20.
let's let's pretend let's just for the
sake of this let's just pretend he's 25.
all right okay 25. so he's got a job uh
making 68 making 70 grand at a financial
calls institution and he wants to move
out okay so he makes enough money right
now that he could go get an apartment
and get his call center job and deliver
for Amazon in the morning or deliver for
whatever and start working multiple jobs
to get this stupid debt paid off he
could
um make a really clear plan with his old
man and say I'm gonna live here for
um three more months I'm gonna have zero
I'm just gonna pay the utility bills I'm
gonna spend no dollars and I'm gonna
start wiping this debt out as quick as I
can I can come up with a plan like that
but he's trying to looks like sounds
like he's trying to do everything all at
the same time he wants to
not live at Dad's house but not have
some debt but also trying to invest buy
a house I got some Investments but I had
to take some loans out against my
investments he's just got too much going
on at the same time right yeah they're
That's a classic case for most people
they don't know why they're not making
progress they're frustrated and they lay
out all the details on paper and you're
like well you could stop doing that and
that and that and that and focus on one
thing with intensity which is getting
out of debt that should be your next
goal which means we're pausing investing
uh which means we're not going to take
out any more debt which is only
exacerbating the problem and so the way
to free yourself from your dad is not to
ask him for a loan so that you can move
out and move out but still be chained to
him with payments exactly that's not
going to help the relationship so
imagine going to the gym George
this is I'm trying to go there which is
quite the stretch I get it all right but
imagine going to the gym do I have to
work out well yeah that's that's kind of
the point of this this whole little this
little story I'm telling you go to the
gym and you get underneath a squat bar
and
you pick up one dumbbell for curls and
you attach one of your legs to one of
those little band things and you do this
on a treadmill right you're gonna you're
not gonna you're not gonna get in good
shape doing that you're gonna get a lot
of broken bones and you're gonna go
nowhere well you might look really cool
you would not absolutely would not I
think it's very similar man like you're
trying to do everything all at one time
I love that like get out of debt first
dude get out of debt make a plan to get
out of your dad's house
um and go from there yeah because on
paper I'm going you make 70 grand you
have 20 grand in debt you can do this
there's people who make less with more
debt that have paid it off
a financial institution call center
which is it's I love the way he said
that a financial institution call center
okay um
he could do that he that job is is going
to be shift oriented like I'm working
the night shift and working the day
shift so you've got plenty of time to
work like crazy on another one two or
three jobs figure it out absolutely all
right let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Valerie is in Charlotte North Carolina
Valerie welcome to the show
hi thanks so much absolutely how can
John and I help
well my daughter just got engaged and
um I would love to know any resources
um or any suggestions you have to set
them
get them started on the right foot you
know we're talking about all the wedding
plans and everything but it's more
important that they start off well what
do you think of this guy
he's lovely good does he have a good
head on his shoulders
he does he's a beautiful young man and
has such a great family we're very
blessed Valerie do you have a crush on
this guy
no not and that's not the Gross Way
Valerie but I mean kind of like man well
he sounds great well I asked because you
high-fived your daughter a little bit
like you're like way to go
we what I'm sorry did you high-five your
daughter like way to go
no as wonderful as he is he's still the
lucky one oh that is the fast answer
he's still not good enough for my baby
okay does your daughter have any debt
uh she does she has twenty one thousand
dollars of college loans okay is she
working full-time now
yes there she is and he's working
full-time in a car she just bought a car
it sounds like that car has payments
attached to it based on your tone
correct okay correct well their A1 uh
once they get married is to combine
finances not before so here you said
what can they do to start off
financially they're engaged right now so
here's what they can do is go through
Financial Peace University as a couple
that is the number one thing I would
recommend to any couple that is engaged
to be married and I'm gonna do you one
better I'm gonna gift it to you to gift
it to them as a present can you do that
for us
God that's so awesome you didn't win
prices right Valerie I love the
excitement though I
guess we'll hang on the line Austin will
pick up tell them here's the thing they
have to do watch all nine lessons create
a budget and report back to you you can
even go through it with them as an
encouragement but man if they can get
out of debt have money in the bank
together learn to dream together create
goals together get on the same page that
is gonna be the number one ticket to
success with their marriage this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls
about money mental health relationships
boundaries career life the pursuit of
happiness you name it John can answer it
he's that good
so the doctor's in the house I'm here to
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call and uh John
you do your show right next door to this
studio the Dr John deloney show what
kind of calls have you been getting is
there a bucket a theme you're seeing
whoo man I would say 95 of the calls
I've been receiving the last few months
have been about
um marriage or romantic relationships
are kids and that's everything from
schools and kids and mental health
Diagnostics to my husband and I don't
know how to talk about sex anymore or
we've had we have three kids we don't
even know each other anymore we just had
our kids leave we don't know what's
going on so it's everything in between
grief how to deal with grief it's it's
it's just doing life man doing life well
I love the way you handle these calls
and you bring such a levity and humor to
all of it somehow in the midst I was
gonna say Pursuit of Happiness is kind
of dumb if you want to call and talk
about that people we can talk about that
um no one's calling in for that no no no
well let's get to the phones Tabitha is
waiting in Savannah Georgia Tabitha
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey George hey John how are y'all doing
great how can we help
so me and my husband have started
working with a smartvestor pro to start
our retirement contributions for moving
forward for our life to be our debt free
other than our mortgage we have our
emergency fund
um we have set aside an extra ten
thousand dollars for a car fund since
both of our cars are six and seven years
old
um so we are just wondering we got the
questions from our smartvester Pro on if
we wanted to max out our Roth IRA for
2022 since we can do that through this
tax season
we are torn on the
like torn on what we should do we do
have the money over our emergency fund
we just are unsure because we are
emotionally attached to the extra money
we have set aside wow is this money
special to you somehow
it's just a peace of mind it's more
emotional you'll talk about that all the
time it's definitely emotional so I'm
like to shove over the 12 000. uh just
kind of makes me a little nervous well
have you guys invested 15 are you at
that threshold yet or is this beyond the
15 percent
so we are starting fresh this year with
our smart investor Pro and we have not
contributed anything up until this point
and we're ending out our 31 years of
this okay we'll be 32 next year is what
I was trying to say what are your
retirement options currently through
your employers
have um retirement through the employer
so it's all
all Roth IRA and then in addition to
that will be a brokerage fund and you're
just getting started with investing
correct okay I would totally fund these
Roth IRAs and the money that you're
emotionally attached to imagine 30 years
from now you go that 6 000 could have
turned into like a hundred thirty years
from now and I didn't do it because I
was emotionally attached to six thousand
when you think about it that way you are
happy to let go of that money knowing it
is going to create an amazing retirement
for you down the road
okay great we just wanted some advice
because we were both torn and can argue
backwards and forwards on either side so
when John can speak to the emotional
side because there's something
underneath that there's something maybe
in your past where you didn't have the
money and you you feel that feeling of
oh my gosh what if
oh for sure yes did you grow up with
scarcity of some sort
I absolutely did um and then we are
finally getting our feet underneath us
we found Dave came to speak in Savannah
in 2018.
um so that's kind of when we started our
journey and then the last year and a
half we've been working on building up
our emergency funds so it's just finally
nice to have that buffer between us and
life and knowing that if something comes
up
we're okay Dave and I were talking just
in a personal conversation a few weeks
ago and we both noted that in the last
few years we've received more calls
about
what I would consider identity
and what I mean by that is
um
you're gonna have to practice not being
anxious all the time
and you're gonna have to practice this
idea of forward thinking thinking about
future Tabitha one of the some of the
research about the actual poverty
mindset is I just need to get through
today
and one of the mindsets that shift from
somebody who grew up in deep poverty to
somebody who is growing wealth is the
ability to say
who can I be in five years or in 10
years and if you look at it as a
character flaw like I just can't do it
I'm not man you it Cascades into a whole
bunch of other drama if you just look at
it as like man that's a set of skills
I've never I've never I've never not
been in poverty so I'm gonna have to
learn how to like when I first had my
Kim my son I would get so frustrated
until I finally realized I've never had
a four-year-old before who just pees
everywhere I've never had that so I am
practicing on how to be a good dad I'm
gonna I'm gonna work really hard I'm
gonna get good wisdom get good advice
and I'm gonna practice it and so what
you're gonna have to do is practice not
being in fight or flight
and that means when you when you feel
your body going ah
think okay I'm just gonna go to the data
and the data says I'm gonna invest this
money so that future Tabitha is going to
be safe
and it's gonna be I'm gonna feel weird
about it it's gonna be hard and I'm
gonna practice it I'm gonna do it anyway
and then the more you practice this the
easier it becomes and then it will
become at some point it becomes fun to
see how much you can sock away for
future dreams and future goals does that
make sense
makes a hundred percent here's the thing
be really graceful and kind to Tabitha
because you're learning a new thing like
if you're just learning Spanish you're
learning gymnastics or something you
wouldn't get mad if you couldn't just do
round off flip-flops on the first day
you would be really happy with your
somersault so just just practice the
somersault for a minute right and then
just be curious when your body tries to
protect you it's kind of a fun way to do
it I think I love it and Tabitha you
know what to do you guys have worked so
hard to get here think about where you
are now versus where you were which is I
owe people a bunch of money we don't
have money in the bank to cover
emergencies and look at the facts on
paper we don't have payments anymore we
have a pile of money in the bank we both
are working with income and if think
about the worst case scenario what could
happen you lose a job okay we have an
emergency fund we'll go get another job
there's gonna be another one and as long
as you have the right Insurance in place
to protect what you're building there's
no reason to kind of have that level of
anxiety or about money on a daily basis
so let me let me I want to say something
real quick
there's no reason to but sometimes our
bodies do it anyway right and so I think
it is
um
it's feeling your body getting anxious
and then asking yourself like all right
what are you trying to protect me from
and you see me I'm smiling it I've I've
even like I've just practiced it over
the last decade whenever I asked my body
that like what do we get anxious about
man and occasionally I know exactly what
it is I might get fired right I know I
am anxious and then I can think okay do
I have money in the bank do I have some
security does my wife have a job okay
we're gonna be okay and I can think
through it but sometimes it's easy to
tell people just quit being anxious
there ain't no reason to be anxious well
thanks dude but my body stop being sad
John is responsible as refraining like
somebody's coming at me with a hatchet
and they're not
um part of that takes time that's right
you gotta feel it and then move on
that's right that's right it's something
you got to practice I like that
practicing that as a habit it's a great
way if you're trying to start new habits
this year one of them is practicing how
to release that anxiety and there's a
few things you do John practices in your
daily life when you feel that how do you
release that
um I think it has like a chemical for me
if I wait until I am full-blown I I have
a bent towards anxiety towards being
anxious about things if I wait until I
am full-blown I'm fried my body's
rattling I've waited too long and so for
me I Gotta Eat Right most the time and I
gotta get good sleep most of the time
and I gotta have relationships most of
the time and I can't owe people money
gum because it really rattles my cage to
know I'm not safe or to know that Toyota
is deciding what I do tomorrow not me
um those are things that I create an
environment that's not anxious right an
unanxious world so that um and it's
taken years to do this this isn't like
some privileged finger like I just
decided today I'm not no dude it was a
hard grinding awful hard work but you
create an ecosystem where the whole
system isn't stressed and then when
things come up your body has the
capacity to handle but what it does
bananas I call somebody go for a walk I
sat in a cold tub this morning because
I'm anxious right now like so I there's
some things you can do but if you wait
that usually it's too late yeah and on
the money side just doing a budget
controlling the things I can control and
on paper you go all right we got this
ta-da it's not out of control I love it
good wisdom there John Moore of your
calls coming up America the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell host of smart money
happy hour with my good friend Rachel
Cruz Join This Hour by Dr John deloney
host of the Dr John deloney show you can
check out those shows on the Ramsey
Network or wherever you listen to
podcasts open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sharon joins us up next in Ohio Sharon
welcome to the show
hi um how are you guys we are doing
great what's going on with you
um so so I am a stay-at-home
home I'm like 65 000 a year
um and he moves up every year and so my
question is
um we still owe my parents around twenty
thousand dollars
um for they helped us buy our house that
we're in right now
um how can I convince my husband to
focus on paying off that debt rather
than just going slowly and then in the
meantime making extra cash here and
there and then using that extra cash for
fun things like vacations and hobbies
and stuff hmm there's something about
owing your parents money
and then you go on vacation and it just
you know I mean the whole thing feels
ugh uh okay I've got to ask how have you
tried so far
um so we have a budget and we
um at this point we're doing like a
certain amount each month like we're
saving it up um or
um and then paying every couple months
we'll give Mom and Dad a check so you're
not doing you're not following the
babies you're not you're not trying to
get out of debt you just have like kind
of a plan you're kind of like messing
around but y'all aren't actually exactly
find a pile of money we'll give them a
little bit Yeah they can have something
yeah pretty much I mean like it is a
goal like we've talked about it both of
us and we know that that's what we want
to do but I guess he's not as intense
about it as I am at this point and being
a stay-at-home mom I don't have any
other income really other than his which
is fine except that when he goes and
spends his extra income other than his
salary on fun stuff so what's the extra
income and I don't really get the extra
fun stuff if that makes sense where's
the extra income coming from
job they had a big project they had to
get done so he got paid extra stuff like
that but he sees this as well this
wasn't in the budget this is extra money
I earned I'm just gonna go spend it how
I want
pretty much yeah I mean when I asked him
when I ask him about it usually he'll
say oh yeah well we can put some of it
towards the loan or whatever
yeah he doesn't have the fire that you
do to get this dead out of your life and
uh exactly when you're in baby step two
it's intense and you can do other plans
but our plan is this is scorched Earth
We're not eating out we're not going on
vacation we are we have one job to do
and that is get this debt out of our
life do you have any other debt outside
of the personal loan to your family
um there's a little left on the mortgage
but otherwise no okay
well I think obviously we got to get him
on the same page and it's hard for you
to do which I'm sure is frustrating
because you don't have the ability to go
create extra income to uh to do this
well actually actually you do okay so
let me hop in here George
um
Sharon
somebody told you that the way you feel
doesn't matter who was that
is that was that when you were little
um possibly okay because you've carried
that message that's a story you were
probably told at some point and now it's
a story you tell yourself that
um you wish things were different but
this is just the way this is
and I know I feel this way but he works
hard and that's fine I'm not gonna fight
him and okay
and you are slowly drowning
and what I would say is a pool of apathy
Fair
yeah that's fair and so
what the reason I asked you earlier what
have you tried and you you did what many
peacekeepers do
is you deflected to well we we have a
budget and we kind of do these things
what that tells me is you have a budget
every month and he either over like a
football game or something he'll look up
and be like yeah that's great
and he'll make some more money and keep
whatever he wants and you are doing this
and you are doing the best you can to
use the word we so that you don't feel
isolated alone am I right
yeah okay so
at some point you're gonna have to
decide and my hope is that you take
initiative on the front end before this
thing turns into resentment because
that's where it's headed is that you
make a call a direct call honey I'm
scared to death
I'm sick of owing my parents money
and it makes me feel less than and it
makes me feel unsafe and I hate going on
vacation having my dad look at the
photos on social media because It
embarrasses me that I had to go ask my
daddy and my mommy for money to buy my a
grown-up house I want this debt out of
our life please join with me on this
yes that is different than hey honey
it's budget time oh okay you see what
I'm saying and here's the thing if he if
he rolls if he rolls his eyes and says
no then you can say that I'm gonna have
to go get a job because I'm not living
like this anymore
right yeah yeah well to be fair he does
help with the budget in fact it's
it's not it's not if I help with the
budget but then go make extra money that
doesn't apply to our goal which is do a
budget so that we can get out of debt
then I'm not really following a plan I'm
just kind of doing what I want to do yes
if if you all had this great agreement
that y'all weren't gonna uh y'all were
married and y'all are gonna hook up with
other people and he was very committed
to you and he hooked up with somebody on
the side you would not say he's a person
of Integrity infidelity
right and so saying we do this budget
together we do it 50 50. yeah cool
you'll talk about it together but y'all
aren't living the y'all the reason you
have a budget is because it gets you to
your goals it helps you feel safe it's
not just like an exercise and yeah he
may be 50 50 he may do the exercise with
you but he's not living it out and you
can't control him all you can control is
you and so I think it's fair for you to
sit down with him and tell him probably
for the first time here's what this is
doing to me I can't breathe
I can't I can't I can't think of my
parents and owing them money anymore can
we please stop and can I ask you one
more question
sure it you're like sorry
um but not sorry
um
what else are you worried about
because this is symptomatic of something
bigger going on in your marriage what is
it
no not really Sharon honestly I mean we
we have a great marriage we really do
and this is just
um this has just been I'd say the last
couple months I think okay one thing I
will mention that could be
um
holding me up a little bit is okay right
now currently in the bank we do have a
little pile of money that we're planning
to give to Mom and Dad
um and I've told him once I was like
well couldn't we give them if you want
to save it up for like a rainy day or
whatever couldn't we give them a little
bit at a time just so I can feel that
motivation that I can still feel like
we're making some sort of progress you
know I told him it doesn't have to be
much and he's like well he would rather
do one chunk one big chunk at a time
he's like if I were mom and dad I would
want a big check not not multiple small
ones or whatever so what if y'all solve
this problem by just asking your dad
foreign
yeah we could do that I guess has there
been any conversation with when you're
going to pay this back to them
no honestly there hasn't no it was quite
it was like five or six years ago when
this first uh when we first borrowed the
money and at that point we were like
yeah Mom and Dad will pay you back but
there wasn't really a timeline attack it
would help your marriage it would help
your relationship with your family and
quite honestly would help the respect
between your husband and your dad
between each other just just got a guy
there
um if you all created a amortization
schedule you all created a schedule and
you printed it out on us on an Excel
spreadsheet or emailed it to each other
and said hey by the way we've created a
payment plan here because I've also
heard George I've heard of these
situations where you get to the end
you're like that's 20 grand and then the
receiver on the other end of this money
goes uh no I've only got 18-4 you still
owe me 1600 more right so Clarity here
Clarity Clarity Clarity let's put a
budget down in front of them talk to
your dad said you want a small monthly
sums you want everything you just say
hey we're painting this off in 10 months
it's two grand a month this thing's
gonna be gone and we're gonna be about
the business of doing that and any extra
work you're doing is going towards that
debt not just for fun money and that is
what doing a budget means as a couple
and it's going to take a hard
conversation it's going to take a better
budget I'm going to gift you one year of
every dollar premium to help you guys
get on that plan hang on the line Austin
we'll gift that to you wishing you guys
the best and getting rid of this debt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show well folks most
of you you're saying good riddance to
last year because it was hard enough
just to keep gas in your car and food in
the fridge and money's still tight a few
days later somehow in 2023 and you're
wondering is this going to be any
different this year well you don't have
to live through another year of stress
and worry I can tell you that much and
that's why we want you to tune in to
Building Wealth in 2023 our free live
stream event on January the 12th we want
to show you that you can still make
progress on your goals build wealth and
have peace with money even in this crazy
economy during the event you're going to
hear from myself Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz
John deloney and Ken Coleman we're going
to talk about how to set goals how to
create margin so that you can build
wealth this year
we're gonna have a lot of fun too and
you're gonna leave fired up for 2023 and
did I mention it's free there's no
reason not to sign up even if you don't
want to watch it's free I like signing
up for free things John so uh even if
the economy feels out of control this
year you don't have to and it's easy to
register just go to ramsaysolutions.com
wealth we'll get you all the information
you need that is ramseysolutions.com
well I love at the end of these things
man some of these as we took this across
the country some of our discussions at
the end of the of the night got off the
rails and so it's just fun to watch
let's see what's going on tune in
there's no script there's no prompter
nope just unfiltered deloney and versus
Rachel versus Dave that is 10 plus
George it just gets awesome there should
not be all five of us on stage but I
think they do it for the team's
entertainment just watching uh the
fireworks show it's gonna be a good time
Building Wealth ramsaysolutions.com
wealth is the place to sign up open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jay's up next in Las
Vegas Jay welcome to the show
thanks guys happy to be getting through
I'm glad you made it what's going on
with you
uh unique but I think simple question
for you all I am in the military
um I'm through the six steps I'm on step
seven with the exception I don't have a
home
because I am trying to save
approximately 50 for it
which is what's kind of leading me to my
question so
being in the military we get what's
called a housing allowance which means
basically I get to live on base not for
free but they just take that allowance I
don't pay any electricity or water rent
it's all included in that
so when I first got to being debt free
and getting my emergency fund set up for
six months I put about 17 500 which is
inclusive of that rent but I'm wondering
now after listening to you guys about
well you really want to buy when it's
down you get a discount you can buy more
stock if I should take some of that
emergency fund
and invest it not because I just want
more but because my rent will always be
covered so while I technically do have
close to 18 Grand and six months of
expenses
I'll never miss out on the housing
allowance unless the military pays this
or fails um which doesn't happen yeah if
that happens we're all uh oh boy we got
bigger we're all yeah fighting our
neighbor for water so that's a whole
different situation here how much of
your of your of that of that emergency
fund is
like rent money
so approximately uh 11 5 12.
um so the way the military works is they
charge you whatever that your allowance
is so it used to be two thousand dollars
we got a 300 increase this year so now
it's 2300 times 6. so let's say now it's
close to the 13.5
okay and what's the time Horizon to
purchase a home
uh realistically sir since I'm I'm not
going to be staying in Las Vegas I would
say six to eight years I'm only seven
years into my career and I'd like to get
back to the South
um so it would not be in the next four
to five years I'm in Las Vegas okay so
outside of the emergency fund how much
do you have saved for this house
so I have 20 000 basically I have uh two
IRAs which I don't use as a retirement
have the 401K
um and then I have about eight thousand
dollars
um in a portfolio is that outside of
retirement
correct yeah I don't count the IRA as
Retirement because I'm not actually
using it for that I have my own 401K
with the 15 and the matching well the
problem is the IRS sees it as Retirement
and so when you go to take that money
out they're going to just Hammer you
with penalties and fees yeah you can't
pull that out brother
oh I I was on an impression after five
years you could pull it out you could
pull out your contribution but that's
just unplugging all of the growth as
well
and so if you've got if you put in 10
and it grew to 30 you're not pulling out
30 without taxes and penalties and fees
so I wouldn't I wouldn't stop using that
as your house fund and just use that for
your retirement fund down the line
okay how much is in there
um I just started out this 2022 when I
got debt free so I got six grand in mind
and six grand in my life cool let's just
leave that there let's use the IRA for
retirement purposes and if you want to
invest you can do that in that brokerage
account and I would be investing in
index funds if you're going to be saving
up for that house
what are you invested in now in that
portfolio
and then to be honest with you sir I'm
not 100 certain it's a swab portfolio
um and I answered some questions about
my level of risk Comfort okay but you're
working with a smart investor Pro on
this
uh well it's it's managed by them my
hands are off okay I want your hands to
be more on I don't want them making any
decisions for you their goal is to guide
you to educate you to then make the
decision so number one your homework is
to figure out what that is invested in
if it's a smart investor Pro the good
news is he's not throwing you into
single stocks and volatile Investments
it's probably in some kind of index fund
or mutual fund so that's good news and
you can use that as far as the emergency
fund goes you could scale back down to
three uh if you've got a real stable
situation but I would go no no less than
three months of expenses and include
that rent in there
okay because your rent is only one part
of your expenses you got to think about
you know max out of pocket with Health
Care other things Vehicles there's a lot
of other things that could go wrong that
could be very costly in today's economy
and so you don't want to go down to 3
000 just because you don't have a lot of
living expenses
oh yeah definitely wouldn't go that low
I was thinking probably about 10. I
think 10 would be my bare minimum
emotionally uh so if you want to go down
to 10 throw the other seven into
investments into those index funds that
would be a wise decision since you're
six to eight years out if it was
anything less than five I'd get a little
squeamish putting my money into the
market knowing I want to buy a house a
few years from now and that's what I'll
tell you I I am George's much like
George is so much better at me
um than me when it's all said and done
George will have more money than me okay
so make make I'm more risk-averse than
John John jumps out of airplane well but
George also reads like he's like well
I'm gonna put it into this fund when I
was saving for a house
this isn't the best Roi on my money but
I put it in a savings account and I
wanted it to be liquid and I wanted to
have it I want to be able to see it and
I didn't want there to be a chance that
I put 85 000 in for a down payment and
then it was 55 000 when I needed to go
buy a house
when it sounds like you're trying to do
is everything all at the same time which
is safe for a house and maximize returns
and this all sound good but you're gonna
make yourself crazy
um especially because you're playing
with and I don't mean this to
pejoratively but you're you're not
playing with a ton of money and so
you're causing yourself a lot of
internal angst over 5000 bucks here or
ten thousand bucks here ten thousand
bucks a lot of money don't get me wrong
but it's not like you're I don't know
where to put a million dollars in this
portfolio that's going to return this
much money you're talking 10 000 bucks
you're talking a couple hundred dollars
here that's going to turn into maybe a
couple of thousand or here so I for me
I'm taking the anxiety out of this thing
I'm taking the stress out of this thing
I'm just gonna open up a savings account
or a money market account and put my
house money in there and by the way if
an emergency comes up that is over that
ten thousand or fifteen thousand dollar
threshold you've set up you could pull
it out of there technically but I'm just
gonna leave it there dude and I'm going
to save my money that way and then I'm
going to have retirement accounts that I
want to grow like George mentioned
separately but again I don't know
there's a right or wrong way to do that
like I think it's your risk tolerance
and your overall like I I've got friends
who love the stress they love the of all
that I like the stress of running into a
building that's on fire and so
everyone's wired differently for what
gets there what gets their heart I like
the stress of trying to get a
reservation at a restaurant last minute
you love that's my version I just go to
Arby's because I don't want to deal with
it like I don't want that but everyone's
got their different levels but that's
how I would do it yeah well uh Jay thank
you so much for your service man we're
cheering you on you sound like you got a
great head on your shoulders when it
comes to this money stuff stay the
course but also keep your finger on the
pulse of what's happening with your
money never just put it on autopilot and
don't look at it don't think about it
you want to make sure you know what's
going on so thanks so much for the call
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to my co-host Dr
John deloney all the folks in the booth
we got Austin we got Bob James Zach
Andrew you name it they're in there
keeping the show float and thank you
America for listening we couldn't do the
show without you I'm getting emotional
just thinking about it and we'll be back
real soon on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by my good friend Dr
John baloney and we are taking your
calls about just about everything mental
health money life career boundaries
whatever's on your mind we're here to
talk about it triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call and Marty is kicking us off this
hour in Charleston South Carolina Marty
welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can John and I help
um I have a question it's a time for me
to get back into the real world um with
a job and
um I'm curious what might be better for
me
um to go after a state or local
government job with less pay and more
benefits or go back to a private sector
to where I maybe make more wages but I
might have to pay a little bit more
um as far as the benefits go where have
you been
um I
um own a small business that didn't take
off as well as I had planned very cool
so you got in the ring you took a couple
of swings and you got knocked down so
now you're like all right I I fought
that dude and he's pretty tough and so
I'm gonna go get another job
yeah it's something like that good for
you man I started a small business with
my buddy um in August and he ended up
passing away in October ah dude I'm so
sorry man so you got you got uh grief on
top of grief man
yeah it's it's been a struggle for sure
um how old are you my wife I'm 34. okay
what about your wife my wife and I have
been um we've been um we've been preying
on it um the whole time because I had a
decent job
um at a construction company as a diesel
mechanic
um and my buddy was like hey man I want
to try going out on my own um would you
come and work with me and I was like
sure I'll give it a shot with you and uh
I was about ready to uh pull the plug on
that because things weren't going very
well for us
um and like I said he passed away in
October and
um two or three days after he passed
away we had got
um a large
um check from a job that we had finished
and so I sat down with my wife and I
told her I said listen I said I can take
this money I can catch us up on a few
bills and I can go ahead and put all of
this in my name and give the business a
shot and and um on just under me
um or I can put it all in the bank and
um and I can go back to working for the
man
um and we thought on it we prayed on it
um but unfortunately there wasn't a
whole lot of time and she supported me
um trying it and it's and it's been a
good run
um but just not good enough and it's to
the point now where uh the bank accounts
are getting a little bit lower than we
both would like and um so I I've
accepted defeat for now
um and I'll go back and and work for the
man I'm just trying to figure out what
would be best I have um try to get wise
counsel from my family and half of them
say you know go and and work for a
government company because the benefits
are great uh your wife is pregnant and
that's not the only kid that you all
plan on having and then some of uh my
other family and friends they say man go
back for where the money's at it'll help
you bounce back quicker and I've
listened to y'all for about a year or so
now and I have the complete Money
Makeover I have the baby step
Millionaires and
um I know that
um I can have retirement
um later on in life through other ways
than a government agency however I never
really paid much attention to the
benefit side of it before Marty the way
you're talking it sounds like you're
just defeated you're beat down you're
you're gonna make this move from a place
of fear and weakness if you're not
careful and I want you to do it from a
place of strength and so I want you to
stop talking that way about yourself
about the idea of work it sounds like
wow man I gotta go work for the man down
like I want you to find something you
love to do and naturally you're going to
get paid well if you're good at that and
it's not an either or in my mind of do I
do it for the benefits of the pay the
private sector can provide both we've
got great benefits here may not be the
same as the government benefits but you
can create your own benefits when you
get paid you know 30 percent more it's
less of a feature at that point so I
don't want you to weigh this Apples to
Apples I want you to look at this whole
thing differently you've boxed yourself
into a corner where there where the
wisdom you've received is it's either
this or it's either this and it's George
either one sucks it's just not true and
I I do want to to man take what George
said and just Mash on it
I could go home every day and be like I
gotta work for the man the man is Dave
and he just takes it all out of me
or I could say dude I get to learn how
to play guitar from Eddie Van Halen I
get to sit by one of the goats of radio
and learn how this thing works and learn
how he runs a business and have access
to all these different opportunities and
get to be with some great editors and I
write a book and I I get to all of that
is perspective and I'm doing the same
job every day and so you can say I gotta
go back to work for the man or dude I I
got in the ring and I took like man my
partner passed away my I tried it on my
own I didn't make it I'm gonna go back
and retool I'm gonna learn some new
skills I'm gonna get back in the game
see what the young kids are doing these
days I'm gonna get back in and somebody
else is gonna pay me to learn how to do
this I'm gonna work really hard for them
you see the the difference in the
attitude my whole my whole voice changes
when I talk like that see what I'm
saying absolutely I do my thing is is I
know that
um I know the business can do well
um I I know it can my grandfather told
me that I was
backed into a corner
um from when I tried to take it over
after my buddy passed he said I was
already in the hole and I did a fine job
so it's not really defeat
um but my my
fear is if I go after a state job that
you have to be in there for a certain
amount of time in order to reap the
benefits of those benefits and what what
I'd really like to do is I'd really like
to go back to work for a company for
maybe five or ten years until my wife
and I are out of debt with the mortgage
and I saved up my emergency fund again I
saved up a cushion for the business I
bought a few more tools that way I could
try this hey Marty's Adventure again
yeah why are you calling us you know
what you're gonna do go do it
go do it
okay listen you got hit in the mouth
real hard
you lost a friend you lost a coat like a
like a business partner man
you got a lot of transition so it's it's
natural to doubt yourself and then be
unsure of The Next Step but the way you
just laid this out man you know exactly
what you want to do you know exactly
what you stop asking people for wisdom
you've asked a thousand people hey man
what do you think about you know you
know what's right for you and your
family go get it man Marty we're gonna
give you one more tool in the tool belt
there and that is Ken Coleman's get
clear assessment as well as his
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose I think that's going to help you
really figure out what that next thing
is so hang on the line Austin will get
you both of those resources and we're
wishing you the best man thanks so much
for the call hey more of your calls
coming up America don't go anywhere
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Dr
John deloney and uh John you've got
these questions for humans conversation
cards and I have the friends second
edition is it safe to assume that I
chose the right Edition for us
yeah I knew it wasn't girls night
workplace felt a little too formal I
thought friends was the next basketball
I see what you're reaching for it wasn't
couples I'll allow it okay I have hand
selected five cards here that we're
gonna play excellent so on each card is
a different prompt and it's a great way
to to connect with friends instead of
staring at our phones all day or to
um Lo-Fi create new friendships with
people that you want to be friends with
kind of like you're doing right now
you're saying I should go to a coffee
shop and just start asking people
questions I mean it's kind of what
you're doing right now so let's go for
it all right first question what
activity recharges you what activity
drains you oh
ah well speaking right now
um what's draining me I have a hard book
deadline and it's just killing me it's
killing me so that having a deadline at
work that
like supersedes everything in your life
from family like just I gotta get this
thing done that drains me just knowing
it's out there just always haunts me
when I wake up I'm thinking about it
when I'm going to sleep I'm thinking
about it
um something that recharges me it sounds
so lame but uh
going to the gym like exercise I knew
that was hanging out with my kids
hanging on my wife like those things
low-key things like that uh really
re-energize me I love it all right after
me recharge I'm gonna go playing music
playing guitar and watching stand-up
comedy excellent that was recharge me
drains me I'm gonna choose yours for
recharge which is working out I'm not at
the point working out feels good and
leaves me the more energy I leave sword
I'm doing it I'm just sad and angry yeah
all right next what life hack have you
discovered that the world needs to know
man it's been several years I've been
doing this and then I got off the the
train and I'm back on
man having a cold plunge outside
especially in the winter it is it is and
for those that don't know the cold
plunge is literally plunging your entire
body into an ice cold bath of water nice
yeah so you can get it they have fancy
ones that um I can't afford yet I'd love
for somebody to send me one be awesome
the coal plunges or I just went to
Tractor Supply and got a trough and I
fill it with water and it is freezing
cold like I get to break the ice out um
especially on on I'm talking like 30
degrees in there yeah it's pretty cold
and uh man just sitting there the
adrenaline rush and the dopamine really
it's pretty amazing our life hacks could
not be more different mine was a toilet
night light so that when you go to the
bathroom in the middle of the night you
don't have to turn all the lights on it
is uh it just turns on when you get
close to it and it lights the bowl it
lights your way
it light your way that's it and it's a
ten dollar amazon you can get them
anyway but it changed my life we're
gonna be the best of friends I can
already tell I can't wait uh what's
something you're avoiding right now
oh
probably a conversation with my wife we
need to have
um that's not probably actually we do
and I'm also avoiding man uh I gotta get
this book done so actually I was just
telling you off here I rented a hotel
this weekend I'm gonna go sit down I
love it I am avoiding working out I got
a fancy gym membership and I've gone I
think twice in the last month my
favorite thing is is you the the money
part will kill you oh yeah like I'm
wasting money oh yeah like Planet
Fitness 10 bucks you're like whatever
but when it's like 100 bucks you want to
throw up every time that that bill comes
out and you want I went okay that was a
hundred times yeah
so it was a hundred dollar gym that's
how I think about it in my mind you
should so I need to go more and I'm
gonna go with you John well I work at a
house so come on over I'll be there
um what is the last text message you
sent read it out loud this was a
dangerous one ooh all right here's mine
it was actually to you uh hey John wanna
hang this weekend what was your last
text the last text I sent was no and
that was in response to me correct
perfect that okay that's the last text I
sent well America if you wanted to know
what our real friendship is like it is
that if we don't have one wow we
couldn't have planned that better all
right last one what's a common phraser
saying that you have no idea what it
means break a leg I I speak all over the
country like you too like we're up on
stages and we're going to be like break
a leg and I always think that's
other than like
get projectile diarrhea when you're up
there like I don't I don't I can't think
of a thing I would want less than a
broken leg I don't understand I know
it's got some like theater etymology and
it's like well it actually means don't
break a lit you know whatever and
they're right uh mine's gotta be
gaslighting I feel like it's the new
cool thing anytime you don't agree with
someone you're just like they're
gaslighting me what does that mean John
a narcissist the person is such a
narcissist because they disagreed with
you yes yes because they asked uh do you
want cream in that coffee and you're
like gosh you're such a narcissist let
me be like dude yeah those two is my
truth
they're just gaslighting me no seriously
like you need a haircut that's not
gaslighting now you need to cut your
hair what is the is there an official
like psychological definition of
gaslighting how do you explain it like
I'm five
um how would I explain gaslighting
gaslighting is
man there's so so many places you could
go here's what I think it is okay how
about that I think it's when you are in
an argument but then the person who's
kind of in the wrong makes you think
you're the crazy one and that there's
not even a problem here and that you're
insane for even thinking there was a
problem yeah gaslighting is really
weaponizing your emotions
for my benefit right I'm gonna use your
feelings against you and so it's a it's
a way to make somebody feel less than
and Crazy For Being Human so uh somebody
who's gaslighting you they will
um
they will
text an old girlfriend and you will say
hey it makes me feel uncomfortable when
you like we're married you're texting an
old girlfriend and somebody's
gaslighting was like oh you're you're
still struggling with your depression
and you're you're still you need to work
on your anxiety oh they flipping and
it's it's it's a very natural feeling to
be concerned when your spouse is texting
an old lover
um and so it's it's taking somebody's
emotions and their feelings and it's
weaponizing it and using it against them
as a as it means it's controlling
reverse UNO card I don't even know what
that means you got to play more Uno John
come on we have it you have a deck of
cards you don't know what Uno is I know
it is gosh
if you want to grab a deck of these cars
there's like 17 editions now and they're
all super fun you can shop them all at
ramsaysolutions.com store it's going to
help you connect with the people you
care about the most we got friends
parents and kids couples even though
we're workplace Edition and by the way
they sold out we got had bajillions of
requests they did sell out during the
holidays and we are getting them back in
we had to go we actually got notified by
A supplier like we're out of paper we
all sold too many and so they are
circling back so we're working it was a
good time to start a card company I'll
tell you what I love it good stuff all
right let's go to the phones the number
to call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jeremy is in Detroit
Jeremy what's going on
how y'all doing we are doing well we're
right up to the clock get straight to
the question
all right um I just turned 36 and I had
nothing to say for my retirement because
I always wasn't a mindset I'm just going
to work until I die Jeremy talk directly
into the phone brother
uh I think I am okay there you go
um
okay that better much better yeah
okay
um I just turned 36 and I don't have any
retirement
um because I always said I worked until
I died
so I never bothered to save anything and
I'm starting to get out of that mindset
now and I just want to know what the
best way to save up for is I've been
following Dave Ramsey and guys on
YouTube
um and I have a thousand dollars and I
paid off three credit cards
um I still have twelve thousand dollars
in credit card debt that that I'm
working on paying with the snowball
method and I have a thirteen thousand
dollar car loan and a nine thousand
dollar personal loan and I have a VA
mortgage on my house I have a hundred
and ten thousand of that
okay so your A1 let's take the mortgage
off the table for following the baby
steps your next step is to get out of
all that Consumer Debt which means we're
not investing a dime right now until
we're out of debt until we have a fully
funded emergency fund then we can move
on to investing and you should be doing
15 at that point from your income into
retirement if you've got a 401k you can
also do an IRA and good gross talk
mutual funds we've got tons of resources
for you at ramsaysolutions.com an
investment calculator to show you that
you can still become a millionaire
you're 36 not 86. you've got your whole
life ahead long way to go man you're
good the best time to plant the tree was
20 years ago the next best time is today
and you are on the path my friend I'm
gonna send you one year Financial Peace
University to show you that it's
possible so hang on the line Austin will
gift that to you and go through that
call us back if we have any questions we
are here for you man
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this hour this is the Ramsay
show triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life your money your
relationships parenting kids whatever
matters to you we are here for it Hunter
joins us up next in Seattle Hunter
welcome to the show
hey John hey George uh how's your
Thursday going going great man we're
happy to talk to you how can we help
yeah yeah so uh my question is on behalf
of some friends that I have that I've
been encouraging them to pay off debt
for about a year and they made some
really great progress It's been super
satisfying I'll see them on this path to
to Financial Freedom and away from this
debt lifestyle
um but my question really comes down to
um my good friend his wife
um they as she is unable to work since
college for the last four years because
of migraines it's been really
challenging for them and while I've been
able to help my friend get a better job
to support him and his wife that pays
about 35 percent more and they've been
able to make way on their student debt
payments
um they
they have really good insurance through
their work I believe it pays 90 to 95 of
everything
um for medical insurance but
um my question comes down to
um they only choose providers that do
not take insurance any insurance which
has costed them several thousand dollars
per month at some points where it's
really taken them away from paying off
their student debt and kind of away from
this lifestyle that they want to achieve
someday and I'm just kind of curious
like if somebody has a really good
um
medical insurance plan but they want to
choose like a naturopath or a
homeopathic provider who does not accept
any insurance and it takes away from
their debt
um you know their goals and their
progress to paying author debt what do
you usually recommend in that situation
I
so one time Hunter I um
was in a grad school class it was a
counseling class
and
I asked my professor hey what happens
when a client says they're gonna go do
something that I know is stupid like
you're gonna ruin everything if you do
this
client tells you hey I'm gonna go have
an affair
and
I know as a clinician I'm not supposed
to tell you I think you're stupid you
shouldn't be doing that
um I'm supposed to help you think
through the ramifications of the choices
you're about to make and my professor
said something profound he said let them
know
I'm with you now
and I'll be with you during uh the
divorce and I'll be with you when you're
splitting up your assets and you're
figuring out where your kids are going
to live
and I'll just be with you
and but in that way I can say here's
what's coming with what you think is a
good decision right now and so I would
tell you you have done a you're a great
friend who loves your friends and you
have felt the success like you felt how
good it feels to feel financially free
and you've become a good
um basically a minister for uh Financial
Freedom right you're so like you just
want to tell everybody about it and just
go prosthetize the rat which I love
and
if you're not careful you end up
hitching
your identity to other people's outcomes
and that's a recipe for you ending up in
Ash just going bananas okay and so what
I would say is these are your friends
they're grown-ups they get to make
whatever decisions they make
you living out the principles and when
they ask your opinion like so one of my
rules is I've stopped giving
um just I would use dude I used to be
the worst I'd go to parties and be like
I wouldn't eat that or you shouldn't do
that or man I can't believe you talk to
her that way yeah dude I was that guy I
was so annoying to be around I was the
worst so now I quit doing that now I
just go have fun and if somebody asks me
I'll say do you want my opinion and uh
they'll say like yeah actually I really
want to know and it happens much rarer
than it used to and when somebody
invites me in I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you what I think but only when I'm
invited in otherwise I'm just gonna go
on about my day because I'm not I am not
responsible for another adult's outcomes
does that make sense yeah yeah for sure
I've never really you know I've never
kind of stated my opinion with that it's
just something I've noticed that like
you know as we kind of read through baby
step millionaires together earlier this
year and it's just something that's kind
of been heavy on my mind as I I really
want the best for them and I want to see
them succeed um you know because they
are my wife and I is probably some of
our closest friends so it's just you
know it comes from a spot of just caring
for them and one sure no dude I I think
they're lucky to have you as a friend
um I also think
man getting in and making armchair
medical decisions for your friends like
well this one's cheaper you should like
man I just wouldn't go down that road
yeah oh yeah no I I want to you know I
want to make it clear I've never you
know thought about doing that at all I
just was kind of curious you know if
you've come across situations like this
and kind of like you know what's kind of
the best path forward yeah Dave Dave's
talked about uh Dave just in a personal
conversation George like Dave was
telling me one of his buddies came over
like dude you got it because Dave's a
car guy and he's like man you got to see
this new car that I just leased and he's
one of Dave's best friends and he showed
up to Dave's house and the Dave didn't
go well let me tell you about the baby
steps Dan right whatever he just like
hey man it's a cool car dude and if he
had said by the way
was this very wise I can assure you Dave
would have let him know what he thought
about it but that that wasn't the just
looking at his car and so if your
friends ask hey are we doing a dumb
thing cause we're trying to get a debt
but also we're going to these bougie
like uh you know concierge medicine
well is there other Alternatives that
might they might be inviting you into
that conversation but just from the
outside in man I just I'd let it ride
I'd let I'd just love my friends and if
they invite me in then I'll I'll give
them my thoughts on it but uh man if
yeah I'll continue doing that then yeah
I think that makes you a great friend
man and and just beginning to release
the outcomes man because you can't own
other adults choices and decisions there
are great wisdom there and Hunter I
appreciate the question John this
reminds me from of when you know the the
vaccine was this hot button issue and
people were going I'm going to lose my
job and we talked about this a lot on
air of going if this is a value you have
this is a moral decision that you're
gonna make you have to accept a
consequence of those decisions that's
right but we're not going to sit here
complain about back and go on Facebook
we just have to go okay that's what I'm
gonna do that's the choice the
consequence of his friends doing this is
it's going to take us longer to get out
of debt yeah and we have a lot more
medical expenses because we're choosing
to go down this path and it sucks to see
your friends do that because he wants
the best for him he's got a great heart
about this but at the end of the day you
go it's going to slow him down all right
it's going to slow their debt Freedom
down by eight months and that's a
decision they made as a family and I
don't have to understand yeah and I've
got friends that do like
uh raise their kids a little bit
differently than I do I've got same
values in there but they do this like I
don't know I'm not doing that and that's
okay right that's okay like it it's if
they invite me into that conversation
then I will give them mine if they're
going hey man really struggling
financially can you figure out any areas
we can come you can look at this for me
yeah I'd go yeah I mean it looks like
you're spending a whole lot on Health
Care is there any other way we could do
this yeah so that it's not and I would
also say this I I have for a couple of
years like I've got one of my closest
friends in the world she's a
um a brilliant homeopathic doctor and
I've called her for some very specific
help for some very specific help for
some very specific needs over the years
and I've gone to a functional medicine
doctor and I've gone to just like a dock
in the box right so hold on what is a
doc in a box a doc in a box I'm so
curious just like on the corner like
um semi emergency clinics sounds really
sketchy not like an Urgent Care yeah I
like that oh I like that okay I think
there's like a stranger set up a little
tent he's like I'm a doctor you're like
me too dude you turn the little thing
it's like
Urgent Care
um just like I don't know the doctor I'm
just going in this because I need XYZ so
I think it's I would be careful about
saying well you shouldn't be going to
this kind of doctor you should man I
would leave that to the people's
particular needs and between their
conversation their medical practitioners
that's good I mean there are some things
you could do to help them with health
expenses as far as gone hey you know if
you load up your HSA which you can put
in the money tax-free it'll grow
tax-free you can deduct that on your
taxes there are some things you can do
regardless of that but again that's
that's a in the weeds there yeah but man
sounds like a great I'm I would be lucky
to have Hunter as a friend I'll tell you
that much my friends are the odds my
friends don't care dude that's the
Carter Drive get something cooler yeah
that's fine I can handle that well hey
more of your calls coming up on the
Ramsey show the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we got
to pay some bills we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney
opened phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five well John every
time I I turn on the news we're seeing
uh more and more about Demar Hamlin and
that awful collapse during the game and
part of that is the trauma and everyone
witnessing that trauma and kind of
grappling with it for the first time
yeah yeah and um I think the latest news
we just heard just a few minutes ago is
that he
was able to talk to doctors now and
um they like he's making tremendous
progress and everybody's really
encouraged about his state right now
which is awesome but it's just one of
those moments when collectively as a
country we just all
saw something happen that was hard to
ever it was hard to watch like a young
man a father and a great guy and
everyone around him says he's a great
guy a hard-working guy and everybody we
had to watch other big tough grown men
that we look up to
man they were weeping they were buried
and they'd lost they thought they lost
their brother and and so it was it was a
tough it was just a tough moment for all
of us man and there's a USA Today
article that connects to the content
that you're putting out there tomorrow
Hamlin's collapse shock viewers fellow
players how to cope after witnessing
trauma it goes on to say everyone saw
the Collision that collapsed the CPR the
ambulance the shotgun players faces
um details were still a little wavy
there but experts say the trauma lingers
for players game attendees and viewers
watching at home and they must process
it before it festers and there's a head
of kinesiology at University of
Connecticut that said it's okay to to
not be okay right now how do you guide
and Coach people on your show kneecap to
kneecap after trauma I think
I'll answer that in two ways one is
we've we
have social media now and so we can
watch it
all day every day replay and replay and
replay and here's another angle and
here's this I remember when the war in
Ukraine broke out
it was just this onslaught of media 24 7
365 and I usually have really good
boundaries and I found myself just
overly consumed I mean I was obsessed
with it and then I realized I am I am
taking this stuff in I'm taking in this
fear and this unknown and this trauma
and watching these bombs and all this
I'm watching all this happen I'm
experiencing this vicariously through my
phone and I can't do anything about it
I'm not being asked to go to war I'm not
being I'm not I'm not being asked to do
any of these things yet I'm putting my
body through the ringer and so the
greatest gift I can give everybody in
this is to turn it off is it turn off
and I'm not Burying my head in the sand
and I'm not so
um
when I heard about this I wasn't
watching the game live I've been through
it I've been seen enough people who have
passed away I've when you watch somebody
get CPR live and they've had cardiac
arrest you will remember that for the
rest of your life because it's not like
it is in the movies it is a visceral
experience to watch somebody who's been
going through Cardiac Arrest get CPR
um I didn't watch this I did stumble on
it like I was scrolling through
something and it would just happen to be
there and I realized oh that's what that
is
um but I chose to not put that image in
my brain instead I focused on saying hey
are you guys doing all right I watched
that game how are you right
um and so that leads me to number so
number one is don't keep going back to
the well on this stuff man like you just
keep putting these images in your head
in your head and your head in your head
and we just have this culture it's like
you've got to man or it's a privilege to
turn off yes yes it is like I I am
choosing to not put those images in my
head over and over again somebody else's
pain is not my entertainment
um and number two is
I'm gonna talk about this and we're
gonna have a conversation about it not
to go through details but more are you
all right are you able to eat are you
able to sleep and out of a whole group
of people everybody's gonna be
traumatized everybody's gonna be hurting
there's gonna be a lot of Tears
one or two or three people may be really
struggling with man I can't get that out
of my head I'm not sleeping okay like my
body's super super anxious or this
reminded me of my dad when he you know
and those are people that need to get a
little bit additional extra help but
there's a it's it's less about going
through the details in fact there's some
research that says don't do a re a
play-by-play don't replay and replay and
replay replay it
um tell me what exactly what you saw and
that's not helpful as much as hey man
I'm here with you and I'm hurting too
how are you and being really open and
vulnerable with people man that's that's
it's just a social norming that's the
way to move forward there yeah good
wisdom there and uh continued awesome
prayers for his recovery yeah um man
what it what a remarkable
I don't know I mean just across the
board it's been pretty neat as again I'm
so far removed for any of this stuff but
just watching how everybody handled it I
know there was
a gajillions of dollars that need this
game needed to be played and they said
hey we're gonna do the right thing by
everybody and I just I applaud everybody
involved in this thing from the coaches
to the medical personnel and quite
honestly the medical personnel that do
15 or 20 minutes of CPR and then put
somebody a young man a really young man
on a in an ambulance everybody's
affected by these things and I spent my
chunk of my career with the nurses and
the doctors and the the folks who were
living in this trauma and then rolling
off the police officers it's tough man
there's a number on people when you see
that stuff and it's just having people
in your life you can sit down and talk
to about it good stuff there John thanks
for your thanks for bringing this up man
absolutely let's go to the phones Alex
is up next in Austin Texas Alex how can
we help today
how are you I'm good man how are you
good uh we actually spoke on um
Instagram called izzio um I just met
your book read for anxiety that's
fantastic thank you thank you man what's
up
so um my girlfriend has um a severe case
of anxiety that I've never really come
across before uh I've never experienced
it
um I personally don't experience anxiety
in my own life but we met at College
about roughly two and a half months ago
and ever since then hurricane attacks um
there's always being made
I'm not entirely sure what to do during
them and um I'll rewind a little bit um
I'm 23 uh she's 19.
and um
I'm sorry we lost you for a second there
what'd you say you were diagnosed
brother Alex you're cutting out on us
here um see let's see if we can get a
better connection on you try now
you still there
yeah it's it's in and out my friend
okay
all right so hey we're uh your call is
important I'm gonna go ahead and put you
on hold here um the the call is
important so I can't hear the back half
of the explanation here but your
question how do I love somebody who's
really struggling with
severe anxiety that's moved into panic
attacks
um how do I stay connected to somebody
who is struggling with something that I
don't struggle with and I'm not I'm not
dealing with
um I think there's a couple of important
moments here one is don't try to fix
somebody
I like she's a broken car engine she's
not don't try to fix her instead of
saying how do I help here how do I fix
you ask yourself how can I be with her
that's number one how can I be with not
fix the second thing is is having these
conversations beforehand
um what do how can I best love you how
can I best be with you when you have a
panic attack some people have panic
attacks need somebody to take them by
the hand
um George one time I was pulled into our
parking lot someone's having a panic
attack in their car and they were
surrounded by people which just you know
situating and I just slowly walked to
the car and grab that person by the hand
and had them come out and I put their
hand on my arm and I put the other hand
on my chest and we walked around the
parking lot just walked and I asked her
I asked this person to look tell me what
color that grass is and let's count
cracks and just I'm gonna bring your
body back here right that works some
people want to be left completely alone
and let the singer ride out so having
that conversation ahead of time how can
I best love you during these moments is
critical so when they do set off
um you already have a plan and then the
third thing is
most of the time
barring you're talking I think uh Alex
we we lost you there but I think you're
talking about epilepsy there is
neurological conditions that that mimic
anxiety which is great it's not great
but they just are those so those are
outside of the bell curve most of the
time
anxiety alarms go off
it's just an alarm letting you know that
you're not safe it's letting you know
you're not safe
letting you know that you're
disconnected that you don't have a
community right that your body is
recognized that you're lonely
um or that you don't have any autonomy
you are being forced to live somebody
else's script
um and so beginning to ask yourself
those bigger questions how do I create a
non-anxious life and that's that's
ultimately the goal the path towards
healing what are these things that are
making me anxious I'm gonna go right
through them right and that you do that
with a good therapist and a good
counselor yeah well a good summary of
your book redefining anxiety as well
really enjoyed that really Alex hey Alex
hang on the line here I'm going to give
you a copy of own your past change your
future um which really it it takes uh
redefining anxiety in and creates a path
right how do we how do we create this
this life that that can be one of
healing that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by one of my best friends in the
world Dr John baloney you know him you
love him best-selling author and host of
the Dr John baloney show mental health
relationship parenting expert this guy
can do it all
and we are here to take your calls and
if you've got a Crossroads you've got
something on your mind you need a second
third opinion that's what we're here for
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Louise starts us off in Atlanta
Luis welcome to the show
hey thank you for having me how's it
going
oh good thank you how can we help today
so um rent is really expensive
true and uh I'm really considering van
life and I wanted to know your opinion
and any tips or
foreign
are you gonna park it down by a river
whatever I can you're gonna have to
Google that reference later dude don't
move into a van down by the river why
are you considering van life why are the
options either uh continue you can't
continue to live where you live rent is
too expensive but the other option is
moving to a van how did you get to that
option
um so I just saw it
on Instagram
and I don't know I thought it was a good
idea
did someone on Instagram say it was a
good idea they said hey life hack can't
afford rent live in a van or they just
I've seen them Hey listen Lewis I I or
was this like the influencers who make
it look really cool yeah dude George
they're amazing tell me if I'm wrong
Lewis like
they take these old vans and they strip
them completely down and do they make
them so rad and they take these awesome
photos like on a beach and it's all
those people have a lot of money
they can afford rent and they live and I
why is it
let me ask you this
what's so great about where you live
that you'd be willing to stay there in a
van
instead of move to another town or get a
roommate or a job where the rent is less
um I guess family is here you know
okay so I love oh let me I love my
family I love them and
every bit of every all my family lives
in the same state they all live in Texas
and then I got an opportunity to go make
different types of money and have a
professional like so I moved because I I
had to and I still get to see my family
I love them I still could see them
regularly but I had to move
um
so Louise you're not buying it what is
your rent let's just talk get to the
numbers 1200. okay are you living alone
with a girlfriend okay are you splitting
the rent
no not yet
so she's not paying and you are
yes sir okay I'm we got 17 more
questions now what is your what's your
income
um I made 2800 I'm 30 30
000 a month
30 000 a month
I'm I'm sorry 30 000 a year 2800 a month
I was gonna say bro why are you calling
us I was like this doesn't matter and
what job are you doing because I want
that job okay so your rent is almost
half of you is that your take-home pay
the 2800
after taxes is that what ends up in your
bank
I I take it all because I work for a
private contractor yes okay
so here's one option
hey girlfriend we can't live together
and I'm gonna go get a roommate and then
your rent just went down to 600 bucks
and now we can breathe
there's one option right if you just
didn't even want to move
the other option is where else can I
live cheaper and that may not be super
viable in your area you may only get
down to a thousand which is still too
much based on your income so the second
question becomes how can I increase my
income to where I can afford the rent
okay so what kind of work are you doing
right now
um HVAC sheet metal installation
okay and you're making how are you
making thirty thousand dollars
are you what's your what's your actual
salary is it about 40 something thousand
no it is 30 30 something okay and you're
you're uh you're you're a 1099
yeah
are you are you putting money back for
taxes are you going to be in the hole
for taxes too
no I'll I'll hold it and then pay it
whenever so you have the money to pay
the taxes come April
um probably not in full yeah dude listen
you have too good of a skill and two and
it's such a high demand area what's
keeping you from going to work for an
HVAC company and making 85 000 a year
plus benefits
I don't have my high school diploma
do you have certification are you just
you can weld
no nothing nothing I just started I'm 20
years old so this is my first lease
whatever so I noticed this
the money is just too much yeah and what
other debt do you have
um I just have one credit card okay is
there a balance on there
yeah how much
nine hundred dollars okay and how much
money do you have in the bank
um right now of 400 plus 900 in savings
you got 400 plus 900.
yeah okay so a thousand dollars is your
starter emergency fund which then leaves
you
um
what's that 300 bucks on top of that to
start paying off this credit card so by
tomorrow we can get a thousand dollars
in the bank and your credit card debt is
down to six hundred that's our next plan
of attack is paying off that credit card
or cutting it up or closing the account
no more credit card we're gonna start
using a debit card do you have one of
those
yes sir okay that is plan number two
start using the debit card now we're
debt free and we have a thousand dollars
in the bank you tracking with me
okay then we're going to continue saving
a emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses not income just expenses so
start getting on a monthly budget I'm
gonna gift you one year of every dollar
premium that is our budgeting tool you
can set up a budget within minutes right
there on your phone on your computer and
it's going to help you pay attention to
every single one of those twenty eight
hundred dollars coming in every month
and you've got to start making a plan
for it and stretching it and part of
that is making hard decisions like
saying hey I can't live with you and I
can't afford rent so I'm gonna have to
move I need to get a roommate uh and I
need to get my cost down in order to
survive
and Louis did you grow up with with a
lot of money in your home or have you
did you grow up with a family that
struggled financially
struggled financially okay I grew up in
this project okay Puerto Rico awesome so
man I'm so proud of you man for I mean
you're hustling you're getting it done
one of the biggest shifts somebody who
grows up in poverty can make in in a
mindset
is this idea of how do I survive right
now which is I want to move to a van
that's how do I survive right now two
where do I want to be in five years and
what do I have to start doing right now
to get there what certifications do I
have to get how do I get into a local
community college how do I start
grinding my way towards where I want to
be in five years that's a totally
different mindset and that's the road we
want you to be on okay my brother and if
you've got to get an extra job right now
if you're gonna get two roommates do
whatever you have to do to get that
Financial stability under use you can
really start to build wealth and break
this generational poverty we are so
proud of you man
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America this is the Ramsay
show I'm George Campbell joined by Dr
John deloney this hour and we are here
for you give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
John the the start of the New Year
always brings a little bit of a of Grace
a little bit of a fresh slate and
everyone starts to write down those
resolutions their goals maybe they're
the same ones you kind of carried over
from last year and you're like oh yeah
forgot
New Year's is my favorite time of the
year and I like it because we just give
each other a mulligan on everything no
matter what's happening you can just
like hey uh I'm I'm just gonna stop uh
whatever using cocaine it's New Year's
and everyone's like cool man like it's
just no matter what's that like like you
just get a mulligan right I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna control delete and give
it another go I just like I know there's
a lot about like man you don't need news
resolutions and you can a new day any
day you don't need to wait till June I
agree with all that but I do like
something about this Collective moment
our culture takes just to be a little
bit reflective and to say hey who do I
want to be this upcoming year or what is
that going to look like or what's a
couple things I want to accomplish this
year I like that I think it's a good
healthy practice and you Rachel Cruz and
myself we got to work on a really cool
new project the Ramsey 2023 gold planner
where you cover the relational side for
goals racial covers spiritual side I
cover the financial side which is really
helpful to have something tactile you
can actually write in carry around with
you around instead of you know having it
in your phone or in your brain yeah and
so that what's really cool I think
that's on sale at the Ramsey store right
now for like 37 bucks so not too late to
get that but I wanted to get your take
on goals because we talk about goals a
lot here at Ramsey Solutions we've got
all kinds of Frameworks and we want you
to set goals in all kinds of areas but
what is the Dr John deloney take so I
think
um
the research is borne out that if you
start if you wrap your life around
Finish Lines
you're going to have a life that
um you're never fulfilled because you
cross that Marathon line and you're
still the same person you did a thing
but you're still George right or the
number of people I like they finally
graduated with their PHD and they're
like
I still don't like myself like it did or
dad didn't magically call and be like
now I'm proud of you that call never
comes right or you make a million
dollars whatever the thing is and so
we're a culture obsessed with goals I
actually think goals can become markers
along the way towards um and I got this
from James Clear
towards a new identity who do I want to
be and so every year my wife and I take
a day or two days and we we get away
from the kids and we
kind of just do a strategic plan for
this upcoming year a reflection of how
we were last year how do we think things
went we look at last year's stuff we
wrote down how did it work out this year
did we and we always start by asking
ourselves who do we want to be this
upcoming year and I want to be a guy
that takes care of my body not a guy
that at the end of the year I'm going to
bench press 230 pounds because if I if I
make that my goal you know what I end up
doing cutting corners and I I will miss
things I won't enjoy my life I will end
up taking a bunch of scare I'll do I'll
cut Corners to get my goal and then I'll
end up more miserable when I'm done
right instead of saying I'm a guy that
takes care of himself I'm a guy that
um
wants to be able to roll around with my
kids when I'm 90. I'm with my grandkids
when I'm 90 so I'm gonna start right now
lift the weights and exercise and and
take I want to be a good husband and a
present father so
um goals are important but for me they
come after identity so my wife and I set
up here's who we're going to be as a
family here's who I want to be I want to
be a reader this year last year I was a
writer this year I want to be this so we
set up the identity who do we want to be
and then I think at Rams we have we
they've we've broken it down here
then you begin to make markers
underneath these things what are the
actions I have to do to backfill this uh
identity because you can't just like
like Michael Scott like I declare
bankruptcy you can't just walk out and
be like I declare I'm healthy
it doesn't work like that you gotta
actually like change your life right you
gotta start moving you start exercising
you're gonna go to counseling whatever
you got to do so right we've at Ramsey
we've identified uh seven goals like
financial goals intellectual goals
family goals spiritual goals physical
career social and if I look at these I
actually these
um fall into
um the different identity buckets my
wife and I set up some of these are are
collapsed right
um but like how many books do you want
to read this year oh my wife's gonna
wants to relearn
um and become more fluent in Spanish and
here's the kind of family we want to
have here's our spiritual goals here's
our physical goal so we've created those
goal lists
um but they are in service to a new
identity they're not the ends in and of
themselves because you will get to the
end of this year completely fried burned
out and you'll have made one hundred
thousand dollars and you'll have no
friends you'll be exhausted and your
body will hate you right that's
different than I'm gonna be a kind of
person that works really hard and
becomes the number one salesman in my
company which means I'm gonna get some
rest I'm gonna make phone calls I'm
gonna to say yes to those coffee things
and the money will take care of itself
on the back end right I love that and we
just had James clear on the latest
entree leadership podcast so I got to
interview him Dave Ramsey's also on that
episode obviously geared tour towards
Business Leaders business owners but so
helpful for all of you listening out
pick up Atomic habits this is an
outstanding read yeah he's brilliant and
I love that idea of identity base
because it's also freeing because then
it's not about benching 230 it's just
man I feel better
here's what's if I'm a guy who takes
care of his body
um
that means occasionally I'm a guy who
just doesn't work out and I rest or I'm
a guy that goes and plays with my kids
because I know that that's going to help
I'm gonna feel better right so it
broadens your Horizon and then inside of
that here's what's now like the the
the nutrition scientist and the
physiologist if you want to run a
marathon cool you're not going to run a
marathon to get healthy you are going to
run a marathon because you have a
physical goal you are a person who does
hard things right really challenging
things and one of those is going to be a
marathon great you're going to pause
your health for a season because you're
going to push your body right and so
that's how they started talking about
some of these things and so cool you're
a person who does really challenging
things awesome do it I I one of ours is
we say yes to Adventures me and my
friend Jeff we're going on on a crazy
hunting trip in a couple weeks I don't
even know what we're getting into but I
said yes to the adventure because that's
the kind of person I want to be versus
I'm gonna go do this thing see yeah well
you're you're reverse engineering it
yeah and you're starting with the
identity which I think is so important
and it's it's really at the heart of the
Ramsay plan we're not getting out of
debt just so we can get out of debt yes
you have to have a goal for that you're
solving for Freedom yes it has to be
specific you have to say I'm paying off
40 000 and 18 months but on the other
side of that you're the kind of person
who doesn't owe anyone anything he
sleeps better at night I laugh really
hard a lot right and that's the
difference yeah that's so good well we
have an amazing resource our team has
put together it's a goal setting guide
and it's completely free you can go to
ramsesolutions.com
goals to check that out that's
ramseysolutions.com
goals John do you want to share any
goals that you've got for this year
um I'll have another book coming out so
I want to like when it comes to goals
goals
um like I want to be a person who writes
as an identity like I want to write
every day instead of these big Marathon
sessions like I've been doing
um and one of the goals underneath that
is I have another number one
best-selling book so I'm gonna have to
work really hard on writing a great book
and on the editing and copywriting
process and I'm going to have to do a
good job get on promoting the book so it
all those all those things are in
service too I just want to be a guy
who's a writer who writes a lot that's
good I'm in that process as well and I'm
trying to create that habit and become
that writer yeah
it stinks mine obviously we've talked
about this on air and off air but taking
care of myself and going to the gym even
when I'm the lankiest most awkward
person in the room and it it's really
hard but part of it is showing up and
James Clear had a great example of a guy
a story where this guy shows up at the
gym for like five minutes then he goes
home goes home every day just five
minutes and goes home people like dude
you're crazy and he's like no I'm the
kind of guy who shows up I go to the gym
I'm a kind of guy to the gym and
eventually you stay 15 minutes and you
go ahead and walk on the treadmill for
10 minutes right you begin to create
these little one degree habits and if
you just get one degree better like I
just want to write for 10 minutes that's
it I'm putting my pen down and then next
month I'm gonna write 15 minutes that's
it I'm gonna put my pen down and over
the course of time you begin to Crave
that routine and you love it yeah yeah
the best example was the book just read
one page that's it you read one page and
then you go all right I read I read 50.
oh my goodness yeah but just showing up
is the first step and uh regardless of
what your goals are we want to help you
get there this year we are here for you
America we've got tons of resources at
ramseysolutions.com you can start with
that goal setting guide at
ramseysolutions.com
goals more of the show coming up foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this hour this is the Ramsay
show and we love January around here and
we generally get a whole bunch of calls
in January because everyone is looking
for a fresh start with their money
especially after a tough couple of years
so if that's you you can't wish for
things to change and just expect it to
happen you've got to do some things
differently when it comes to money
you've got to have a plan and we can
teach you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you're going to learn step by
step how to pay off debt how to build
wealth and guys nearly 10 million people
have taken FPU
they have followed this plan they've
changed their lives I was one of those
people 10 years ago this stuff works
don't try to reinvent it don't try to
just take the pieces you like I'm
telling you if you go all in on this
plan it changes everything and when you
intentionally follow the focus intensity
this year will be different I guarantee
it you're gonna have more peace in your
finances and your life so start
Financial Peace University right now
just go to ramsaysolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com
FPU Regina is up next in San Antonio
Regina welcome to the show
hi thanks so much for taking my call I
appreciate it absolutely so here's
here's my quick question well obviously
quick and here's my question what do you
do when you can't pay the minimums
that's the bottom line question my four
walls are up and everything else is done
but I just can't get to all of the debts
with the minimums um do I just let them
keep calling and just keep answering
them and tell them I'll get to them when
I can do I try to negotiate the minimums
what do I do well number one you're
doing a great step in just proactively
communicating with them and letting them
know hey here's where I'm at here's the
bills here's the order I'm paying them
in here's how much I can give you this
month
and if you do that it's better than you
ignoring the calls and it going to
collections and have people coming after
you I want you calling them more than
they call you
okay so what are these payments
how many do you have
um uh there are
um
several of them
um they total up to 555 778 555
000
is this all personal debt
um personal pretty much personal debt
does that include your mortgage yeah no
that does not include our mortgage and
there's a there's some land in there
there's
um there's
um credit cards
um what are the big chunks
million bucks in a debt Regina what
happened
just a whole lot of a little bit of
everything you know you you stop paying
attention and you just you know you just
kind of keep going you make good money
and you think that you're invincible and
here and one day you turn around and
that's where you are what's your
household income
uh 200. okay and is it just you is our
spouse
yeah my uh yeah I have a spouse okay and
how much of this is kind of the Consumer
Debt outside of the land
what kind of data are we talking
um we're still at four because the land
is only 100. okay so what's the rest of
the four I'm confused here is student
loans credit cards car payments
student loans credit cards medical bills
personal loans
uh yep medical bills personal loans yep
yep I'm running out of things to even
throw out there Regina I mean if you you
have them and that's really all but
there's just a lot of what's the biggest
what's the big ones like how much credit
card debt are we talking
um the credit card debt is uh fifty
thousand
um personal the the Consumer loans are
probably the biggest ones those are
uh in the 150 range what was that for
what did you buy
just a whole lot of stuff like stuff for
the house what are we talking I don't I
don't even like if you gave me a half
million dollars I don't know that I'd
have enough ideas to spend it like that
so I'm just I have a dark curiosity at
this point
okay so are is your husband on the same
page that you guys are going to get
intense about this and go scorched Earth
and live like broke people because you
are broke people
no he's not on the same page what does
he want to do no
um file for bankruptcy
and he just resigned to go let's just
keep going to dead it's fine when we
have to go bankrupt we'll go bankrupt
and start over
yep
oh Regina
Regina don't do that
I'm not
definitely well we need both parties
involved to be on the same page because
you can't do this alone
what do you what do you all do for a
living
[Music]
so you know what declaring bankruptcy
does to marriages individuals like you
know absolutely I mean your your lives
are going to be a living hell yeah for
the next decade if you do this they're
not going to be because we're not filing
they're not good all right um I'll tell
you what you can do you're gonna sell
everything that you can sell everything
the land is getting sold boxes are
getting sold Bye Felicia the crap that
you bought with the credit cards is
getting sold goodbye all of it all of it
we are we're working on it um so if you
sold everything you can sell what would
that add up to out of the 555
um
he's saying that we
agree
um let's see the line is one
cars sell them your Camry people these
are nice cars I imagine yeah no no we
don't what's your house worth
uh our house is worth five five eighty
and what do you owe on that
uh four
okay so if we downsized
we could clear 180 and get something
smaller right or even rent for a while
for a while
here's what we're trying to
um and I know you know this best want to
say it clear
y'all are in a desperate situation
y'all make a lot of money which is good
you'll make a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year it's great but y'all are
broke broke broke and you're you're one
illness away you're one layoff away from
this whole house of cards coming down on
you and I know you know that right you
feel it yep absolutely so have you sat
down with your husband and said honey
I can't breathe
I'm scared to death
and I'm not going to be a per I'm not
going to file bankruptcy because it's
not that's not Integris we have the
money we're just choosing to not live
this life because here's the deal y'all
are going to file bankruptcy and you're
going to run this thing right back up
because you all have not changed the
core issue which is y'all don't have a
plan y'all aren't together on the same
page and you don't have the discipline
that that getting out of this thing
together is going to give you
um do you guys have kids
uh they're old I wouldn't empty nesters
okay
how old are you two
um in our 50s
and when do you plan on retiring
um well at this rate never never yeah
never well here's the deal I have a lot
of hope that the situation can turn
around and it can actually turn around
pretty quickly because it's a really
quick huge shovel
because if you sell the house that's
you're gonna get 180 there if you sell
everything else you could probably clear
another 200 right
yeah for sure so that's already 380 out
of the 555 and now making 200 we're
throwing 100 at the deck because we're
living on nothing and all of a sudden
we're debt-free in a couple years
right so bankruptcy doesn't make sense
when it's that clear of a path
but he has to get on the same page and I
can I can give you a tool to help you
get there I can't force him and that
tool is going to be Financial Peace
University so I'm going to give that to
you do you think he'd go through that
with you all nine lessons getting on a
budget I've already tried I used to
teach it 10 years ago why doesn't he
want to do it
no he doesn't why
he thinks there's nothing new to learn
is he not looking at the in the mirror
or at the bank statement what
yeah
Hey listen he's not on the phone so we
can't there's no sense in in going after
him what I would tell you is for the
first time in a long time in your
marriage
I would let him know how terrified you
are
and let him know I'm not interested in
signing off on bankruptcy papers we make
enough money we can be debt free in a
couple of years we got to change our
life
you guys are gonna need counseling yes
if he's not willing to do this because
there's a lot deeper issues I'm still
going to gift you Financial Peace
University because I have hope for you
guys but man this is a big situation and
counseling is a lot cheaper than divorce
I'll tell you that much so I really
really hope this all works out please
call us back if you need any help we are
here for you Regina this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show our scripture of
the day comes from Psalm 42 11. why my
soul are you downcast why so Disturbed
within me put your hope in God for I
will yet Praise Him My Savior and my God
Roy T Bennett said never lose hope
storms make people stronger and never
last forever
well John I can't help I grew up on the
coast some storms are pretty rough he's
talking about the storms of life
but it's more of a Kelly Clarkson what
doesn't kill you makes you makes you
stronger more than that it doesn't kill
your mates okay I knew he was gonna sing
it because some uh some storms were
pretty there's no coming back from but
that's that's another conversation well
speaking of storms John I gotta talk
about our last call from Regina 555
000 in Consumer Debt not including the
400 000 mortgage and they make 200 000
husbands not on the same page he's just
good to resign to bankruptcy and I was
asking you off air at what point in a
marriage do you go I we can't continue
like this yeah I'm out like what is that
conversation like well I I take a much
broader view of the idea of fidelity
um of cheating if you will and if I cash
out of the marriage I'm cheating you out
of
this agreement this the union that we
agreed upon right that we both joined
together and so cheating for me is a
much bigger thing than did you kiss
somebody like that it's a it's a not
just a romantic exactly it is a somebody
is walking away from the mirror they are
slowly gonna drown you
um abuse is another like I'm just slowly
pushing you underwater I refuse to
participate in a budget I'm spending
money I'm gotta uh I'm choosing to
gamble our money away here I'm drinking
away here
um got secret accounts over here I'm
choosing to slowly drag you behind my
car
and I
at some point everybody's got a Breaking
Point and so I will never tell somebody
you need to leave that person
um except in very very rare situations
I'm not gonna tell somebody go get
divorced
um but I do think people need to have
hard conversations and when they do to
say hey I'm worth more than this life
and when you have that conversation
here's what I need
you have to have an or what statement
and you have to be prepared for that
moment to say or I'm out or
um I'm going to sell everything I can
and
um you're gonna have to be resigned to
the fact that we're not gonna have a
couch because I'm selling it because I'm
not living like this anymore like
whatever your or what statement is you
got to be able to make that I just have
a much
I'm just I mean I just kind of jaded
when it comes to that I've just seen
people hide behind that
I'm not dating anybody else so I can't
and you just and people get trapped and
I just I just don't I don't think that's
the spirit of it yeah but but again
that's that's that's that's that's my
theological hot take on it but
um I I
that kind of call just it it breaks my
heart because
what I mean what do you do what do you
do man what do you do and that's that's
a powerful ugly mess well it's a and
it's a reminder that we can't control
other people which is so frustrating
because you just wish I could just get
him to see my side and do what I need
you can't do that and the way you laid
it out this is is Caustic as this moment
is for them it's a two-year problem
and it's a two-year problem that you and
I both know they could have a marriage
in their 50s on the back end of this
that is better than any point in their
entire marriage and their sex life can
be better and their Adventure life could
be better and their communication can be
better and their relationship with their
kids all that can change in two years of
we are gonna go make this thing right
and we you and I both we get to see that
over and over on debt-free screen we get
to see people change their lives and so
it's maddening on this side of it to be
like oh or we're just gonna I'm just
gonna declare bankruptcy just just quick
complaining I'm going to quit and I'm
gonna be out and there's there's a
moment for bankruptcy hear me say it but
I'ma quit and uh
good good luck like man there's just a
resignation that drives me a little bit
mad making 200 Grand a year just deep
breaths John that's all we can do that's
all we can control let's go to the
phones Tom is waiting for us in New York
City Tom welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks gentlemen um I'll be quick
because I know you you know you have a
show to move along
um you are the show Tom we're glad
you're here man all right thank you so
much guys I really appreciate it Happy
2023.
um I called in a few weeks ago when I
got on the air I had a question about
term life insurance versus whole life
insurance and Dave convinced me to get
rid of mine and my wife's whole policies
and switch to term policies which are in
the process of doing I mean the process
in other words you know just waiting for
the paperwork to complete I'm not going
to terminate the whole policies until
the sorry until the terms kick in but
that should be next month hey did you
catch a lot of hell for it did they give
you did they give you grief over it no
um I think I was on the air that day no
no we're talking about yeah the actual
the the Brokers oh the whole life sales
people were they angry that you were
trying to cancel no no no you know why
because I have a my my sister's friend
is my agent and I just said this is what
I want to do and just go and do it and I
got a couple of uh quotes on the side
from different insurance companies to
make sure that the policy rate that they
I was getting from her was as low as
some of the other companies were giving
me and it's I guess the you know the
tables they all use the same tables I'm
assuming because all the policy quotes
were pretty much identical gotcha very
well my wife's ages
um yeah so what the thing is I'm gonna
be saving about 400 a month I'm doing we
do it I'm still doing a long-term
policies we're still doing 30-year
policies because my my family just tend
to tend to live pretty long so that
frees up 400 a month roughly for me and
what I want to do is invest that
obviously I have a daughter that I want
to make sure I've got money for so my
question is probably probably over
complicating things I quickly went and
opened up an IRA I already we have a
401k which is pretty well funded and my
question was would that extra and I also
I have uh you know 529 plan I've got a
wedding fund I've got all these things
set up for her as much as I can I know
she's only two and I'm already got all
these
um
all right you're a planner you're a
planner good for you yeah I'm a planner
exactly because I have my long story
short that wasn't done for me and so I
wanted to I'm trying to make sure my
daughter has you know doesn't have the
worries that I had to the struggle I had
to get through to get myself to school
um so with that 400 a month I'm trying
to decide if I should just increase my
401k contribution by that amount or I
should I opened up a separate Ira or
invest the money into an IRA like is
there an advantage to having multiple
retirement accounts or is it fine if I
just put it all into my my company's uh
401K which and they do also have the
option of you know a traditional and a
roths okay I do a 50 50 split that was
going to be my question uh there is
advantages on the types of accounts
because of the tax treatment so with the
Roth you're not gonna have to pay taxes
on that when you withdraw in retirement
and there are no rmds required minimum
distributions like there would be on the
traditional side so there is a benefit
there but as far as having multiple
accounts you're not really doing
anything you're just kind of
complicating things on that side so I'll
tell you what I do I do 15 into my Roth
401k here at Ramsay Solutions and that's
it
that's it okay and so if you get to that
15 there now is your income high enough
that you would max out the 401K and need
to go elsewhere
yes I probably if I did the full 15 I
would exceed the the the allow that
amount that you're allowed to put in
annually on a 401K yeah so you have
other options and a smart investor Pro
can walk you through those I'll give you
some ideas though you can still
contribute to a traditional uh Ira you
may not be eligible for the Roth IRA
because of your income and so you can
still do the traditional there's also an
after-tax 401k contribution you can look
into with your employer and see if
you're eligible for that
um one thing you hit on which I wasn't
aware of and actually that could change
things dramatically you just said and I
want to make sure I understand that if a
Roth IRA does not have a required
minimum distribution
that's correct so I could retire at 70
hypothetically live off my 401k and that
Roth 401k if I did have a separate
account that could just continue to grow
and I wouldn't have to touch it exactly
correct that might be actually I might
want to disagree with that might be a
good a good idea for me because that's
really what I wanted to do I wanted to
have this account that continues to grow
for my daughter that essentially becomes
if I my goal is not to touch that so it
continues to grow you could live off of
the 401K and I would still switch I
would go full Roth in that 401k and you
can do a backdoor Roth IRA so if you
contribute to that traditional IRA you
can then flip around and make it a Roth
by paying taxes on that so there are a
lot of ways to do this once you have
that level of income and you're at the
level of wealth building you don't have
a paid for a house though right
uh only eighteen thousand dollars left
so once you pay that thing off then the
the world is your oyster you can
increase your investing increase your
giving increase spending have fun man
I'm so proud of you wow I love Tom I
could talk to Tom all day long time my
people appreciate the call man this guy
is gonna leave a legacy for his kids and
you heard him he said that wasn't done
for me I want to do it for my kids and
that is a noble goal there you go I love
it complicated but Noble yes that was
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to all the folks in the
booth to my co-host Dr John deloney and
you America until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]